one of the reasons California at least
in my opinion brings in so many illegal
immigrants is that it inflates their
census numbers which then grants them
more congressional seats and more
electoral votes right so I always tell
people that you know they'll say illegal
immigrants don't vote they don't vote
and I'm like well at the federal level
they don't need to
if the census tracks X many people and
they get a I think uh into the 2010s
they had one extra congressional seat
and Electoral College vote one out of
538 votes you're absolutely right that's
that's that's that's a lot of power to
gain from doing what they're doing I
think they're called ghost districts
Maxine Waters gets elected with like
seven votes because her district is all
illegal aliens but by now in California
everything they've been coming for a
long time they are voting in California
we're just bringing in more and more and
more and why don't the Republicans do
anything about it
um and that's the donors want the cheap
labor